nein die Nebenwirkungen sind mit
Sicherheit geringer als das Risiko an
der Krankheit zu sterben das heißt aber
noch lange nicht dass es keine
Nebenwirkung
gibt also die Sache mit dem Profit lass
ich mal außen vor das ist eine Frage die
müsste man an die Pharmaindustrie
vielleicht
richten weil die die Ärzte werden mit
der Impfung mit Sicherheit nicht reich
dafür gibt es ein wirklich nur ein
minimales
anerkennungshonorar aber es gibt
natürlich Nebenwirkung das ist ja immer
wieder beschrieben es gibt lokale
Schwellungen es gibt 10% der Menschen
die das auch als sehr unangenehm
empfinden dass in dem Muskel für einen
Tag wie ein Druckgefühl entsteht und
etwa 1% der Menschen bekommt auch Fieber
für einen Tag also Grippe ähnliche
Symptome das ist aber völlig normal das
gibt's bei der normalen Grippeimpfung
auch